the World Cup in Cattails becoming the
most entertaining perhaps of all time a
bit of disappointment for those who
attempted to overshadow the tournament
with sanctimonious virtue signaling
including memorabilities Germany players
who covered their mouths before their
game against Japan before losing the
game 2-1 and crashing out of the
tournament they were mildly widely
mocked by Japanese supporters and katari
TV hosts who cover their mouths of wave
goodbyes the Germans got the first
flight home well Arsenal Legend arson
Wenger now FIFA set of development
summed it up rather well
and the teams as well who were mentally
ready like Jurgen said that the mindset
to focus on competition and not on
political demonstrations
well I'm thrilled to be joined now by
the sports casting Ledger Bob Costas one
of America's greatest sporting
commentators a veteran of a record 12
Olympic Games winning no fewer than 28
Emmy Awards for his Peerless commentary
Bob uh what a treat to have you on Piers
Morgan and says so thank you so much
nice bears great to see you again even
from a distance I have one Daytime Emmy
and I've never covered an Olympic so
you're slightly ahead of me and I bow I
bow to your superiority quite willingly
and this whole issue Bob I just couldn't
think of a better person to talk to
about where the line is drawn between
political activism or social justice
activism for that matter and sports and
this issue of Sport washing whether it's
in golf with the live golfers and the
PGA at War whether it's what we've been
seeing in in Qatar at the world cup with
people saying they're going to protest
they're not protesting they're being
ridiculed for it others like the Iranian
players making a genuinely powerful
stand against oppression of their women
back home going right back perhaps to
Colin Kaepernick who was of course the
NFL player who took the knee for the
first time and the England players at
this world cup are still taking the knee
uh in in his his honor I guess because
he was the one who started it so it's a
lot of stuff going on on in this area
what is your overview of political
activism and Sport
I think Pierce we have to make
distinctions from one situation to
another one person to another just
because I may agree with a general cause
or issue and with the person's right to
make a statement doesn't mean that I
have to agree with everything they say
under that manner Colin Kaepernick is a
good example there's no question even if
some people may overstate the severity
there's no question that police reform
is an important issue in the United
States and where it needs to be reformed
the burden primarily falls upon people
of color in the United States that's
legitimate but then when Colin
Kaepernick subsequently says I don't
vote because the oppressors will never
allow you to vote your way out of your
oppression when he said that Barack
Obama was President I guess he didn't
vote When Donald Trump ran against
Hillary Clinton and then Donald Trump
became president that's a silly and
naive thing to say even if I respect the
initial point that Colin Kaepernick
wanted to make within the this year's
World Cup the Iranians not only are
making a very important point it's a
courageous point to make because heaven
knows what might happen to any of them
when they return home and they're
directly involved in that some might say
that others at a safe distance covering
their mouths or whatever are merely
virtue signals but then it all circles
back to the ioc in their case putting
two Olympics in China another one in
Vladimir Putin's Russia and FIFA now
going to Qatar as you have stated
previously and I agree with this
obviously every nation has flaws and
problems and issues and things that they
need to correct and shame in their past
and maybe in some cases in an ongoing
way but then there are nations in the
here and now we're not talking about
history in the here and now that are
fundamental human rights abusers Qatar
is one of those China is certainly one
of those Putin's Russia is one of those
and these athletes will never have a
platform that that will draw as many
eyes and make as large an impact as they
do at an Olympics or at a World Cup and
it's ironic that FIFA and the ioc say
let's keep politics out of this please
keep politics out of this but they're
the ones who put politics in it by
placing these events in places like
Qatar and Sochi and in Beijing so as
long as the the protest whatever it may
be is not within the match or the game
itself because people do want to watch
the game or the match for its own sake
and it's very exciting I think you
undermine your own cause if you get in
the way of the game itself but
surrounding the game or for commentators
in the programming that precedes the
game or at halftime or post game then I
think it's okay you see well a a
brilliant response is as I would have
expected and very thoughtful a nuanced
in many places I would take issue I
think about a couple of things you said
the main one I think is this there's a
lot of I think over the top virtue
signaling about Qatar from the UK in
particular not from America
interestingly but in the UK a lot of
sort of anger built up in the very last
minute about a World Cup that was
awarded 12 years ago the Middle East has
never had a World Cup if the stick to
beat the Middle East on human rights is
ill treatment of Migrant workers and
LGBT rights for example then you're
basically saying you can't have a sports
tournament in the Middle East at all
because they would all have similar
issues with migrant worker treatment and
outlawing LGBT rights completely in most
countries but you'd also have the same
situation in Africa you'd have the same
situation in China the same situation in
vast ways of India of Russia and so on
and so I I think what I would say back
to you Bob on that point once you start
putting the moral Halo on about human
rights
I'm not sure you can end up with many
places in the world which are clean
enough to actually host say a World Cup
and I'll throw it back to you in this
way you and I have both actually got
into trouble at different times in our
careers in America you're more
successful than mine about gun control
for example you you expressed a view
about gun control uh when you were on
air once and got a lot of blow back I
did a lot more and got a lot more blow
back and got told to go back to the UK
but the next World Cup is in America uh
shared with Canada and Mexico should
people be taking a strident view for
example about gun violence in America as
an issue about abortion laws which just
dramatically change which are very
contentious in many other parts of the
world what America's done there in other
words if if you continue down the road
of putting a Halo on and deciding who is
fit to host these things I think you've
got to be consistent and accept that
every country including America
including Britain which helped America
legally invade Iraq of course in 2003
that we all have actually pretty big
abuses which would be quite hard to
defend
yeah there are matters of degree the
points you make are legitimate and by
the way just parenthetically as you know
my point about guns in America and as it
affects athletes was to say that there
is a gun culture in America not to take
issue with the fundamental idea of the
Second Amendment which is a big deal in
the United States but even if you
believe in the Second Amendment you
should also be able to recognize that
there's a lot of irresponsibility
surrounding guns and some of it had
crossed over into sports so that was the
comment I was trying to make but
sometimes people get irrational about
certain things hear what they want to
hear and take it from there so forgive
me for that parenthetical aside I think
the point you're making is legitimate
but it's a question of degree if we're
looking for a perfect Nation maybe you'd
have to hold every Olympics in
Switzerland which ironically enough is
where the ioc is located in lausanne but
we're talking about degree the United
States most certainly has its problems
and athletes historically and sometimes
movingly have registered their
complaints and their protests about that
but Qatar
Putin's Russia Beijing they are
fundamental human rights abusers it's
definitive about them rather than flaws
that the Nations we're talking about the
United Kingdom or the UK uh America
Canada they are actively trying to
address however and perfectly however
haltingly it's within their their DNA
it's within the American Constitution to
address these uh inequities and
injustices whereas it is the policy of
the governments of Qatar and China and
Putin's Russia to oppress people and
engage in in many cases Russia in this
case uh International treachery did the
United States make a huge mistake Post 9
11 in invading Iraq yes they did but I
think you could make a strong case that
that is not fundamentally what the
United States is about
I mean it's an interesting rejoinder I
mean obviously having been in Qatar last
week there's a lot of I think resentment
and raised eyebrows about what they
perceive to be the West's moral
hypocrisy and they feel quite strongly
about it that they've been over
demonized and the West under demonizes
itself and doesn't want to turn the same
critical eye to its own moral failings
and they pointed like in the UK for
example we have appalling drug abuse now
in our country it's sort of Rife with
drugs now appalling knife crime
um you know all sorts of metrics from
sort of moral uh degeneration if you
like which is anathema to a lot of
people in the Middle East where they
don't there's drug drug laws are
incredibly Draconian you know there's
very little knife crime at the crime we
have in the UK and so on so it was
actually being there on the ground was
really quite interesting it's not to
defend everything that they stand for
but I do think it's a commonality
through the Middle East uh pretty much
what Qatar represents and they believe
they're representing the whole region
with the World Cup and I have to say
having been there Bob it was a very good
atmosphere it felt very safe everything
was you know running very smoothly and
it's not like uh I know the Germans ran
the trains well under Hitler it's more I
was there they all seem to be having a
pretty good time I have to say
well the World Cup is a wonderful event
and from what I hear from a distance uh
it has been run smoothly just as you say
uh
oh one thing I heard repeatedly when I
hosted the Olympics I always asked the
heads of the ioc when they brought them
in for an interview what is it with this
seeming affinity for authoritarian
Nations uh with the ioc and the answer
always was we feel that by holding an
Olympics anywhere it helps to spread the
Olympic ideals of equality and diversity
and democracy it helps to spread those
ideas
how's that working out
with uh with China how's that working
out with Putin's Russia and we'll see if
there are any reforms in Qatar or Iran I
tend to doubt it right Bob I can talk to
you all night uh what I wanted to ask
you before I let you go you've
interviewed so many Fascinating People
in the sporting world if you could
literally
if it was your last hour on Earth which
I hope won't come for a very long time
who would you of every sports sports men
and woman you've ever met who would you
most like to spend that hour with
Dead or Alive well if it's the one
all right well then you just answered
the question Dead or Alive because of my
Affinity for baseball I would like to
sit Babe Ruth down with Jackie Robinson
Babe Ruth was the greatest player
pre-integration Jackie Robinson is not
the greatest player although he's a
great player but he's perhaps the most
significant player uh in the modern
history of baseball and to have them
talk not only about baseball but about
the country they grew up in uh Ruth at
the uh the turn of the century and
Jackie Robinson in the middle of the
20th century that's the interview I'd
like to conduct
brilliant I would I would choose sir
Donald Bradman who statistically an
Australian batsman cricket uh
statistically the greatest Sportsman of
all time the gap between him and the
second place international average
player was greater than the gap between
one and two of any other sport in the
world
you know I once referred to Sir Donald
in a piece on HBO as the Babe Ruth yes
of cricket and in fact there's a great
picture of the two of the meeting It's a
Wonderful Village yeah Bradman and Babe
Ruth it's an amazing picture uh Bob
thank you so much for joining me I
honestly I could talk to you all night
you're such a fascinating guy and I
really appreciate it
thank you pierce hope we talk again soon
good to talk to you all the best